[Music]
welcome back to a super special episode
of the careful boys where today we have
both
Jared and Mike hey Dr Mike can I call
you Dr Mike what whatever Dr Mike the
whatever you [__] puny
[__] you you didn't make it to the
muscle
table you just chill out you're here
with me are you a real doctor if you
don't have a l code on that's true you
know I am I'm curious about your your
dog I've heard some great stuff
everybody says you're extremely
intelligent no big deal no deal tell us
who he is he's being so in my opinion um
he's holding Chopstick RP team both the
Jared and Mike are the the
chck keep going areful and you're just
not helping yeah yeah yeah you're making
us look bad give me a spoon one of them
upside down cone hats I'm American
that's a pork by the
way I'm American okay get a lampshade on
this guy they're one of the Premier and
top authorities when it comes uh to the
fitness space because as we know there's
a lot of like mumbo jumbo out there and
everything they do is science backed um
Mike's an actual Professor uh Jared met
Mike in college when he was a student in
his class so to me it's like I think
everything kind of funnels upwards and
they're like the coaches coach you know
you have a lot of coaches out there but
who do the coaches get their information
from and to me they're the coaches coach
that's a
[Music]
great what school do you teach
at like a like a school for
children my parole officer says I'm not
allowed to
mention children like yes so you met him
at what fifth grade yeah what's the
timeline
College what is the whole story you ever
seen um like college girls gone
wild oh yeah similar College white boys
that he's like Professor how do I get
muscular and I'm like here's the Jim
[__] his ass out he was tied up for a
long time he took it really well jar
they hired me so I wouldn't R him out
shut the [__] up about this Jared wanted
extra credit [__] [__] [__] yeah yeah
um jez now that I'm actually going to
say where I
work is that a secret oh [__] I didn't
know super fun job okay uh I didn't want
to burn you out technically I teach at
at Leman College in the Bronx in New
York Co do you still teach there after
running the RP stuff or is it like so RP
is older than my teaching job there oh
wow yeah I teach there cuz Dr Brad
shonfeld who invented hypertrophy he's
like the greatest hypertrophy scientist
muscle grow any article you've ever read
about is Shan feld's on there I didn't
know H hyy was
ay mad wisdom obviously the buff people
here we understand but for like other
people who aren't buffed like what is
hypertrophy yeah some crazy ass [__] you
know what I'm saying um it's just muscle
it's just like a a nerdy [__] term
for just getting jacked oh yeah we got
nerd CHS for all the [__] if you Fells
are interested that's cool that's like
saying [__] or fellacio you know I
like that you got to latinize it fu is
faltio you've been cheating at me I mean
yeah but like wait wait who's falatio so
you started teaching there because he
was there already or he was starting a
master's program and he asked me to come
uh apply for the job to be a professor
and I was like well Dr Brad shonfeld um
and it's cool it keeps you involved in
the academy a little bit CU I had been
teaching uh for my whole sort of
professional career and doing RP and
then at some point I just wished to only
RP yeah and then uh Brad got me back
into the I was trying to understand what
that said I thought it said Renaissance
penetration because of the wrinkles but
that's that's that's
my that's the division I work
foration he's the president of that
backwards why is it backwards letters
that's
mirror you should just get what upside
down so like this even better that's a
good idea just for you yeah you're a
queen is like daily affirmations he's
got too strong a neck and too big a
chest he's like I actually this may not
be the time for this but I have like I
have about a zillion pet peeves that are
all kind of jokes not really serious but
like some old clever [__] on your
shirt I hate that [__] F you just
wearing a t-shirt you little
[__] funny cuz we had a whole whole
whole apparel you ever have clever
[__] yeah
that's you drive your car and you're
having like a bad day and you see
someone just happy gol lucky like
crossing the street they got some little
clever [__] on their shirt you just want
to get out of the car and be like you're
never going to beat
anything that smile off your I cannot
relate feelings of anger what hell is
wrong with
you a
lot so what you teach again so everyone
could sign up for you to
class or dumb t-shirts to class um
Advanced hypertrophy and strength uh
training Theory so it's only master's
program that class only Masters a
masters in getting buffed he has a PHD
in getting buff he doesn't even make it
sound cool cuz if he's on the [__]
the school photo board I'm like oh [__]
he knows what he's talking about that's
true cuz I wouldn't follow you if you're
fat [__] up man that's
fat that's like [__] looking at that
advanced calculus [__] and seeing the
old ass asian lady you like I'm
down more to teach me that I can
learn no way I'm going to understand I'm
used up sponge at this point so what is
what is
RP um Renaissance periodization thank
you than you that is that some clever
[__] on your shirt I hate that [__] I
feel like I need if you ever walking
across the road and he sees you in his
car I'm running you better watch out
dude you want some of that Yakuza [__] I
know to [__] with you maybe you could
explain cuz I would say maybe less than
half of this audience even knows what
Fitness is in general Fu you don't know
Fitness start
dick in your mouth
that's that's very mean kind of podcast
yeah but yeah start from like a super
low low common denamic porn producer
side to me let's make money
gentlemen go
on Asian man on man it's a demographic
for everything oh yeah I would say half
of our viewers probably think Fitness is
walking around the
block I would say half of our viewers
think Fitness is Bart yeah Bart is fit I
swear we have a quarter of our viewers
actually know some yeah yeah yeah I
would say the majority don't know as
much so maybe if you could share what uh
RP actually is what do you guys do
totally he's asking you to be serious
yes this is difficult transition so we
started out as a company that just helps
people get informed about Fitness so we
have a couple of ebooks that we publish
that are super cheap we put out tons of
content on our YouTube for free all the
time with a paid section of YouTube
which you can get even more in-depth
super nerd content if that's not good
enough then we have coaches on our staff
20 some odd coaches most of them have
phds or registered dietitians or they're
like world class athletes some
combination of all that and they'll
coach you they're kind of the best
coaches in the world and Jared's one of
them except me you picked the worst one
it's like an honorable mention he the
worst two first places cuz of him that's
true got double first that's more
attestment to you than me but no it's to
you that's so cute you guys hey hey
isn't he annoying to work with though
like he's all just like what about this
what about this and just like just do
what I
say like like I'm like no Bart you can't
do the card okay cool cool cool what
about jump rope damn
it but yeah and then on top of that we
have
apps you know what I'm saying so hyper
yeah yeah what you want isn't the is
your app uh almost like AI based or no I
mean like it's it depends on what
definition of AI you use is is it modern
AI truly cutting absolutely not uh is it
technically an expert system uh program
yes it falls under the general category
of AI if you keep it real broad like is
your dog smart like yeah compared to
[__] dogs he is he's not going to
help you with Calculus or whatever he
might [__] on the bed cuz on your app
you could even put like um hurt back or
whatever right and then the the
exercises that it suggests will kind of
work around even some of injuries no it
it thinks of [__] it for sure
intuitive you you just you just Inuit it
and you tell it hey how sore are you how
much do you feel like training more you
type in all your numbers and it just
gives you new progressions it just tells
you what to do next integrating all the
knowledge that you give it and that it
has so it's a it's a coach in your
pocket we have one for training and we
have one for diet so if you want to get
more jacked you do what the training
thing says if you really want to get
more jacked or get leaner or whatever or
get prettier so you can finally have
someone to love you finally once in your
life a lot of that yeah you're like damn
you're selling it
I'm in feels so good to be loved which
job's more fun like the running the RP
stuff or the or being a
professor [__] this is on live
TV I'm going to lie to you politician
style going on YouTube yeah I [__]
hate being a professor in my [__]
school's watching this like you idiot
all [__] idiots these [__] kids
yeah Brad shonfeld's watching this
that's kind of tight the politically
correct response is both uh both are
uniquely challenging and and fun
wow thank you good job me I feel like
you told us the answer yes yes we could
just shut up now yeah but FRFR cuz we're
trying to keep it real on this
[__] for real that's all we do
um if I do nothing except stare at and
manipulate equations and mathematical
Concepts I don't want to be anywhere
else in a white that's your dream job
dream I just want to disappear into the
Matrix J got the same idea is that RP or
the school yeah whatever whoever gives
me opportunity I get more of that kind
of work with RP oh wow yeah cuz like
designing blank ass faces do you like
research what he say research a lot I
research a few things you know what I'm
saying on the toilet cure and
[__] so how did y'all meet oh [__] boy
yeah like the the for real for real real
is this like like a Christian podcast or
some [__] yeah
obious Christian singles yeah this is
great why do you have two knives and
practice there's more questions than
answers here there's way more questions
actually maybe there's
a true I wanted this one but I had to do
the double edge like one needed a friend
it was buy one get one 50% off one knife
is so lonely John Wick can't do cool
stuff with just one knife I mean pretty
cool stuff but if there's two holy [__]
it's even better and if you hold one
forwards and one's backwards that's good
the cinematics real tactical but for
real uh I think we touched on it last
time I was on here Mike is my professor
in Missouri it was his first
professorship job I had just started
like a scientific training and dieting
Association at the University and I kind
of knew of him from ETSU because there's
another really common known professor in
sports science his name is um Dr Stone
what's his first name Mike Mike Stone Dr
Mike did you sign up for his class cuz
you already knew who he was uh yeah
there were two professors that taught
most of the classes he would teach and I
was like I'm going to sign up for his
but I was actually a CA ra Community
advisor resident advisor if you know
what that is like I'm in charge of a
floor person who deals with drunk
undergrad basically so ID have to go to
school two weeks early and then he was
that was his first year as a professor
so I just saw him in the gym and I was
like hey what's up I know who you are
you be my uh the mentor to this
Association I just started on campus and
we literally just met in the gym and
then I was a student and then did you go
like so went to the office who do you
get your steroids from cuz need some
basically that's basically what happened
oh it wasn't like hey you need a spot
and then you start a
conversation he's not trying to pick me
up godamn
it hey but hey for all all due respect
your game is strong as [__] I felt I
felt kind of seduced by that I'm not
training but I love a thank you thank
you for asking I kind of feel like I do
now I need a spot in life this is a
dating podcast
remember Christian Singles christian
single how did you guys end up working
in the same company was he like a star
student you're like he felt real bad for
me and hired me I don't know why he said
he's a dummy read he's like I'm in
college I'm like I was a diversity
higher just not enough white guys white
white trash is a little mini column on
the diversity that's true that's true
well because there's no Asian column you
[__] well you're you're you're
a white woman I'm not I'm
33.4% Chinese get the [__] out of here I
will not I'm sorry the Caucasian side of
you leave so I can see the
Chinese he he's the only one that
doesn't believe me that's so crazy a
doctor dude he know wild yeah he can see
right through me that's crazy plus my
wife's asan
s he knows me why do you think I'm here
I'm the only white person here I mean
Jared and I are here I mean like
diversity highers like we are yeah
Anthony's 33% white you're what exactly
you Traer ass
[__] I guess I'm wied by proxy
cuz my in-laws yeah
Exist by proy because his knives I dude
the knives d i I just got comfortable
with that and you you again threw me off
I'm like oh [__] they're still there
speaking of knives I was flying over to
see Jared uh two days ago and to Vegas
and I get on the flight and I'm like
it's from New York so it's like 5 hours
so I'm like 70 milligrams of THD should
sort this out no
problem and then course I started
watching Blade the
origin the first one that's the best one
the only one that's the best there are
so the the way the vampires talk to each
other and he talks to them cuz there's
pure Bloods and not pure Bloods that's
the most racist [__]
iire with any other ethic group that
movie get
canceled he's like I was born to kill
you
suckers he's like they're into
everything they control the whole
economy I was
like about Je is
he the vampire medium yeah they hate
sunlight and they're small and really
pale white and they come from northern
Europe I'm like
uhoh anti-Semitism no it's just vampires
it turns out so
funny I hate him I hate them all
randomly she's like why don't you quit
it so stressfully got to kill every last
one [__] and you know he like
slipped up and he was white
mother you can't say white he's like
yeah sorry sorry vampire we'll cut that
scat holy [__] I got to watch blade
again know that these are the Easter
eggs miss the director's cut that that
scenes in there get out of here yeah
yeah he says white and the director's
cut really what I knew it yeah yeah yeah
and there was a there was an Asian scene
too cuz they got to rep all the the sub
races of vampire you guys you remember
that it was like an old Asian man right
there was tons of old Asian men and they
were watching like these Japanese girls
do like this terrible pop hip-hop
situation but they're all the school
girl outfits so that's it it was like
nonsense but it was really popular which
is like generally what I assume K-pop
generation after generation what was
going to be into the little young
Japanese school girl I was not afraid of
that scene or upset about it at all I
didn't know he was going love the sca
dude it was like only the of this scene
the best scene so how do you two work
together
today
barely I hate this [__]
guy a lot of resentment this is going to
end up being therapy for you guys to
bring us back together I'm glad I'm in
the middle that's why
you're um you know Jared and I we do
pretty different things at RP he does
much more of the coaching I do more of
the like technical work but like with
apps and stuff like that but I rope him
in every now and again for that and he
never ropes me in for coaching cuz I'm
no good at that [__] to be honest um but
then he will do tons of coaching and
then we collab a lot on YouTube where
he'll come in and we'll train various
peoples for the YouTubes and they want
to be hurt by our muscle growth training
techniques that's cool so your guys'
jobs are pretty like compartmentalized
where like you guys technically don't
cross very much except for during the
content like YouTube and then we both
pitch app stuff but like a lot of the
like the algorithms and stuff Mike
basically wrote like how [__] long
ago 3 years four years ago 2018 or yeah
2018 crazy program too no no not at all
oh [__] but we have a team of super
amazing Engineers that know how to
program oh they know yeah yo fellas I
don't want to brag but we got hella Jews
and Asians on this [__] man
that's Silicon
Valley recipe for Success walk around
that's like
programmers do you guys miss each other
since you guys live on opposite sides of
the country J comes to visit every now
yeah I do usually during a crisis but I
know would you guys like to hear about
the nature of the crisis o yes can we
hear about it yeah I'm going to play bad
breakup [__] bad breakup [__] dramati it
a bit oh no problem oh my God was the
crisis oh boy looks like seriously like
oh really concerned don't worry Jared's
fine all right so uh Jared is has what
he calls you guys I think have heard
this podcast before he's fully connected
What's called the Jerry Force the Jerry
Force yes the Jerry oh yeah and it
unites this podcast roughly three groups
of people it's a Jerry pool yeah yeah
Southeast Asians but don't worry if
you're any kind of Asian and you happen
to be
either Browner than average or have very
distinct facial features like big ass
lips or some big ass eyes and some [__]
like that you say field workers or your
or your eyes are really like I can't
I'll get cancelled for doing it like
that the more like that you look like
the less you look like a white woman the
more your shot at the title is nearly
guaranteed I see and then so uh there's
then there's Latinas same rules apply
the more cocko you look technical
term Jared he can't he'd love to talk to
you he see you through the force he
can't feel you but if you're one those
two demographics and the third is just
the Jerry himself and the force is kind
of like it's created by all the living
creatures in it and it's reinforced by
them and Jerry can feel the Jerry's
they're all called Jerry's every time I
drive to Cali it's just like you could
start to it's like a magnet
for it's hard to keep your eye on the
road yeah yeah he's aware of all things
some indigenous draw that he has you
know he likes the he likes the ancient
blood and it takes a special said
indigenous yeah he's said you're he's
like you could have just said field
workers you could just field workers so
there's a Jerry crisis so so every now
and again you see the the the Jerry
channel is a vessel for
love and true the sometimes the volume
and the intensity of the love it um
exceeds the capacity of the best and
what what happens when the love gets out
of the Jerry force is called technically
in the industry it's called
drama
and now look like everyone is a
beautiful person on this Earth we're all
United in harmony you know what I got to
say after this
but I'm not going to say [__] about
Southeast Asians yeah cuz my wife at
home southeast Asia M she's not angry at
all getting a dick cut off I say too
much but Latinas
they got that fire and when you [__]
with the Latino it's all good it's all
good intentions when the drama happens
Latinos are like way overprepared for
the [__] escalates drama in your life if
you're a Latina it's like if the zombie
Holocaust finally happens and you're
just happen to be like a [__]
Republican gun toting [__] Del you
got like you're waiting for this I
couldn't wait long enough is this true
this nailed Latino wives right there
yeah right there that's that true she
warns me
and they saying [__] are you safe at
home not sometimes while the camera's on
them they're like that's not true at all
that's not true it depends on do not
have any drama whatsoever I don't know
what you're talking about you guys cre
you guys are full of [__] I can not
agree with this so sometimes when the
Jerry he gets a little too much of the
drama he leaves the epicenters of uh
brownness we'll call them and he he goes
to Detroit Michigan we have misery cold
drama and a shitload of
whites we got some
[__] that's why heit but Jerry so at
that point he's not even looking for
love he comes to Detroit there could
even be great they could even be Latinos
sa Asians there he's just overreached
love there was too much drama recently
and you have to go to yeah it's like
when you're peeking for a powerlifting
meet and you're really fatigued that
last week so you got to pull back a
little bit easy warm up weights only
yeah I don't know what that means
in D de okay no no video chats no
Snapchats I don't think you should go to
any gyms in Westminster so or garden
Garden Grove don't go to any Orange
County in General Orange County might
cause some problems don't go to any of
those gyms or go to every single
one who cares seea the other
way feel free to take the opposite of
my
for